hi I'm Amy polar and I'm standing in
front of a bunch of books which means
I'm smart and you have something to
learn from me let's get
started in my class we're going to
discuss how these improv principles
affect your real life it's for people
working in relationships parents you
know how do you deal with kind of the
everyday humanness of Life who's next I
need GRE like
boyfriend
can't be halfway in when you see someone
half commit to something hell is the
hallway right you're just kind of stuck
straddling Between Two Worlds it limits
you from connection experience and being
in the present moment don't bail on your
partners so many sketches at SNL bombed
but everybody held on to that bucking
bronco until it rode out of town it is
so hard to hang in but man people do not
forget
that I am a big proponent of doing
things before your ready you can watch
the parade go by and you can say I'm
just going to wait for the perfect float
but if we are all waiting to be 100%
ready the parade will go by I'm Amy
polar and this is American Idol Master
[Music]
Class